yes sir so i welcome you all
in this particular webinar and
uh i especially welcome dr vrcena which
is currently dean research in punjab
university
as a professor from umass university
institute of pharmaceutical sciences
and uh i'm lucky to have you sir here
especially because with this shorter
duration
of a request you agree to join us
thank you very much rockstar my pleasure
yeah so his area of research
drug delivery and pharmaceutical
technology is very much interested in
that thing
and the reason of being invited him also
because he's the person who's
responsible for
handling all the research activity
related to whole punjab university
and he's very supportive person and i
really see the
your presence will be very productive
and fruitful
so i introduce uh i welcome
all of the participant also and welcome
the present speaker
i need to do few things near i need to
say so i belong to punjab university
and it is it is uh
especially working in the center of
system biology and bioinformatics
as you know punjab university is a very
long history and
recently it's a very academically very
good performing and we're
also having second all india ranking
second in initially ranking of
ranking innovation so these are the few
thing which uh
which i can say and the theme of the
two-day webinar is especially deals with
the precision medicine
and the use of the data sciences and
this webinar is a color
collaborative effort and the
special collaboration and invitation
from a pine bi-tech
from usa and our center of punjab
university
and this webinar especially deals with
precision medicine which
changes the way of understanding the way
we
see disease and medicine assets in the
current scenario
i welcome a ceo of the company pine
biotech
ilya bronski also which will be speaking
and taking the session uh
there is little background about him
he's a bioinformatician and a data
scientist and is a person
who is responsible managing this project
management and
creating lot of commercially related
project linked with
bioinformatics and data science so he is
the person which is managing and
facilitating and
collaborating with a lot of other
scientists throughout the world
mainly uh his his
interest is in dealing with the quality
education
and research in the area of
bioinformatics
so i welcome you also sir ilikaji are
you there
hello so uh the duration of this seminar
or this webinar will be
one and a half hours we will intuitively
start on
8 30 and will conclude within 101 or 30
minutes
the basically broad topic will be
covered by the deduction of
a program what is the
big data and bioinformatics overview
and what is the program especially the
program of omic logic
what sort of education platform they
have and
how the punjabi industry can be helpful
our student
how they can integrate in the area of
collaboration research or maybe a
creation of a lot of startup
of what i say so with this
is a small introduction i welcome
the present speaker of today thank you
yeah thank you so can we start
yeah yes all right um great and thank
you
before we before we start sir doctor
rockstar can you say some word uh so
that we our audience can understand uh
let me say one thing we nearly we got
250 registered participants
and when we see uh going through the
list so they are from
india and abroad and mainly within india
they're covering more than seven to
eight states that
include punjab bihar patna chandigarh
and haryana karnataka kerala and we have
participants from madhya pradesh
maharashtra many places within india
and from abroad we have participants
from usa thailand
pakistan poland nigeria iran italy
so you can have an understanding of the
diversity of the peoples are interested
and we are broadly these are mostly
seventy percent of the participants are
from
student and we are basically from
biology background for the licenses
uh this is a basic the structure of the
participant also and now i welcome dr
cena to say
a few words so that we can start yes sir
thank you professor ashu uh for
giving me the opportunity to be the part
of this
webinar first of all i welcome
today's speaker uh dr
ella grotzky the founder ceo of
pine biotech and welcome user
and certainly your words your
words of the topic will certainly
enlighten our student
as well as the audience but the part of
this particular webinar the topic
selected by the organizer is very very
pertinent and
it is need of the hour as we know that
the conventional way of delivering the
drug
is is a is it is like
one size fits all that means
a drug is given to someone uh which we
think
will be suited for every type of the
person
but everyone's need is different and
that is
how why we talk of the personalized
medicine
the personalized medicine is an emerging
practice of medicine
that uses indus individuals genetic
profile
to guide decisions in regard to the
prevention
diagnosis and treatment of the disease
it is taking over the concept of one
size fits
all by utilizing the patient genetic
profile
in designing proper medication or
therapy
and administer it using the proper dose
and resin
you can easily think of
the situation uh in which we
administered a drug today
say for example a person suffering from
diabetes
we administer the insulin subcutaneously
it is not the tailor made it is not
dependent
rather on the amount of glucose present
in the blood
which is much more required so sometimes
a fasted patient if he takes the insulin
injection
it can lead to the hypoglycemic shock
also
so anything which can be tailor-made
it will always be beneficial or anything
which is
targeted one that can be beneficial for
each and every patient so individualized
pre-season or personalized medicine
provides a genomic
blueprint to determine which person's
unique
disease susceptibility define
preventive measures and enable targeted
therapy to prove
provide the wellness to the patient
and that is required a person
who is having different of different age
having different weight having different
race and so many different
genomic structure that that their needs
will be different
so this topic is very very pertinent
and it will certainly uh will helpful
in treating the disease very precisely
and accurately both things are required
and
this preciseness of this particular
therapy
makes it more relevant as compared to
the present
heat and trial way of giving the
medication we have already
trying as a pharmaceutical scientist
to solve such this problem by giving
some targeted
delivery the insulin gate is one of the
system which you will see that the the
device will release the drug uh insulin
depending upon the glucose level so it
contains
some enzyme which sends the
insulin level in the blood and depending
on that
it converts the glucose into some
gluconic acid and that acid
generates that is the that lowers the ph
and that lowering of the ph
is sensed by a smart polymer and that
helps in the release of the trust
that's how we are dealing with this but
the personalized medicine is much more
beyond this
i am very happy that this particular
topic has been selected
uh i will request my students to
listen very carefully and ask
questions to the speaker because
he is having the knowledge of this
particular domain and
he uh and get the maximum benefit
because
yeah he has devoted his busy
time for us and i'm really thankful dr
uh ila brodsky for this that you have uh
squeeze time for us and uh
and you will be interacting with our
student and difficulty member
thanks once again to all the
participants
students and i just
hand over the uh the to
mr
to the head of the department to proceed
for the
proceedings of the webinar thanks a lot
thank you dr thank you very much so we
can start uh
by inviting you are you there
yes i'm uh here thank you very much for
the introduction
and um i i think you've uh summarized my
presentation so maybe i should just open
the
forum for questions
well thank you for this introduction
it's great to be here and thank you
again for
uh making this a forum that i hope will
be both
a short presentation and also an
opportunity for us to interact and get
to know each other
and i am going to be looking forward to
continuing this
relationship in the future so let me
start off
uh by introducing myself my name is elia
brodsky i am one of the co-founders and
currently the
ceo of pine biotech what a company does
is we have a vision to enhance human
health and well-being
by enabling biological research and
discovery with relevant data
solutions and support our mission is to
simplify bioinformatics and advance
research through our modular and
intuitive multi-omics analysis and
integration platform
that is powered by both human experience
and artificial
intelligence what we offer are training
programs
research support and big data analytics
tools and solutions that are designed
for research and biomedical discovery by
a wide range of users
and our mission is to make it possible
to do cutting-edge research
and solve big data challenges by
developing innovative solutions that are
easy to use
providing training to use them
effectively and arrive at sound and
reproducible results
so i hope that today in this
presentation i'll be able to offer you a
glimpse into some of the
types of projects that we deal with and
also encourage you to think about how
your expertise in bioinformatics and
your interest in data science could be
a way to make a difference in people's
lives
so beyond myself our company just
briefly tell you about the company
we're essentially an extension of a
bioinformatics academic research center
at the university of haifa in israel and
i
am privileged to work with a team of an
international
uh of an international team
uh that includes a number of people like
the founders
of the company dr alfred tauber who has
a biomedical and biochemical background
and dr
lena broski who has a collection of
publications and expertise and algorithm
design and big data analytics
as well as our team here that you're
probably already familiar with
dr mohit mazumdar and
beeps at this was who you have been
interacting with but there are many
others that are making this possible and
so i'm grateful to work in this
diverse and talented team so let's talk
about
bioinformatics for precision medicine
and what i want to focus about on today
is the aspect of precision and
personalization that we'll talk about in
the context of clinical applications
but also the clinical ecosystem so the
system
is comprised of a number of different
areas that all
are being disrupted by this availability
and accessibility of big data
and the key is bioinformatics right so
i'm talking to you as
those that are interested in
bioinformatics that understand
the data science and the data role
in biological discovery and application
translational research
and so i'm encouraging you to view this
presentation as an
opportunity to leverage your skills both
in academia but also thinking about
industry and the need for professionals
in this with these kinds of skills that
are able to solve
pressing challenges related to human
health
so the future of medicine as was already
pointed out
is driven uh by availability of data
the expansion and standardization of
high throughput sequencing
that is resulting in medical practice
that is both
ultra personalized and precise and this
feature is really driven
by high quality precision data
deep analytical expertise that is
required from
all participants of this interaction and
particularly at the systems level
it is the ability to integrate a diverse
collection of different types of data
sets so let's take a look a little bit
at
what how did we arrive here and kind of
like what is
characterizing the situation today uh so
a little history on genomic data so
about 70 years ago the structure and
function of dna was discovered and
it was it took about 50 years from
that point in time until we had the
human genome project
and the human genome was sequenced
eventually the technology became more
accessible and now
we have over 100 000 human genomes and
as you can imagine the cost and the
technology
driving this change plays a major role
in the adoption of next generation
sequencing
and making it clinically relevant so
let's take
take a look a little bit at the
economics of this data
so this growth in high throughput data
is driven by this cheaper faster and
more efficient sequencing
so the different formats of sequence
thing today we call it next generation
sequencing or high throughput sequencing
the technology improved so much that
from around 100 million dollars in 2001
that it cost to sequence the human
genome it took
uh three million dollars to sequent a
genome
in 2008 and by 2017
the cost of sequencing a genome was
approaching the 1 000 mark
today that price is even cheaper so
just recently it was announced uh
that you can sequence the genome for
just one hundred dollars
and this number this 100 genome
was previously considered to be the
breaking point of when
genomic sequencing is really going to
make a huge
impact so this happened as you can see
just in 2020 and
february 26 this announcement was made
and so
why is that number so important well the
economic reason for this number being so
important is because
your other clinical tests are
much more expensive so in fact you can
see here a few examples
x-ray about 250 dollars computed
tomography about 800
nuclear medicine about 600 so you're
really putting next generation
sequencing
in a comparable bracket in terms of a
clinical application
which makes it now a component of
biomedical data
that could be regularly relied on by
clinicians and outside of biomedical
research
only the significance of that is
that the economics of data are hugely
important for clinical practice
so medical data or simply clinical data
is the type of information that
clinicians have been relying on for
centuries
it's temperature heart rate other vitals
and that data is sort of on the surface
that means that it is
typically measured quickly it is cheap
to generate
and it is already covered by a standard
practice in terms of coverage of
insurance but with the advent of
cellular and molecular biology we've
learned how health and disease
are driven by what's happening deeper
and
not only deeper at the tissue or the
internal level
but it's really driven a process that is
sub-cellular so subcellular processes
the genomic variation the transcriptomic
variation
proteomics epigenomics and metagenomics
together
really drive disease and eventually are
manifested in these clinical phenotypes
that are observed and are relied on
to explore identify and treat
disease and so as a result
this is now biomedical data that
includes the combination of both
clinical
and omics data or the information about
the manifestation of disease
as well as the underlying biology that
is composed of
layers of different types of objects so
as a result of this process we have
an explosion of data but a lag
in the information that this data care
carries so with increased reliance on
data and much lower costs of generating
very detailed
and huge data sets at each clinical
interaction
we're now faced with this explosion in
data availability but
a growing informational lag really
complicates the translation of this data
to become practical and impactful
insights
at the point of care by clinicians and
benefit to the patient
and so that is what we call the analysis
gap
it's the difference between our ability
to generate new data
and the ability to analyze and interpret
it for the benefit of an individual
patient
so this gap is a disconnect between
lab clinicians researchers and
clinicians that form
the biomedical research ecosystem and
the translation of these
insights are really dependent on closing
this gap
and this gap it breaks up the cycle of
innovation
due to the lack of data-driven research
skills among otherwise effective
biomedical personnel
that is dealing with increasing demands
and a
changing unpredictable landscape in
terms of
more and more complex conditions that
we're trying to address
so what types of industries are being
disrupted by this process
so in this pandemic i think it's become
very clear
how availability of data on its own
is not really going to be the solution
for treating and intervening in this
kind of
outbreak and many other more subtle
conditions
are really a crisis in the works and so
we can
see that all aspects of this biomedical
ecosystem
the research the hospital and the
pharmaceutical industry
are affected by this gap between
the data that is accessible and cheaper
to generate and
the ability to extract meaningful
insights
from this data as a whole understanding
disease and being able
to make practical decisions at the
patient clinical
level so that brings us to
back to the topic of this webinar right
bioinformatics role the role of
bioinformatics the role of
bioinformaticians
the role of data science skills for all
those
that are interested in precision
medicine and so
this role includes the ability to
process
big data effectively structuring that
data organizing that data making that
data
possible to work with the rapid
hypothesis testing and analysis
that includes complex approaches such as
machine learning
and various deep knowledge of
biostatistical methodology
as well as the ability to integrate
annotate
and make sense of identified patterns so
who should be concerned
with these topics and who should have
these kinds of skills
the goal i think is for these skills to
be equally adopted across
the whole scale of data generation
the analysis of this data as well as the
clinical application of these data sets
by decision makers right so the
translation the path
from the labs where this data is
generated
to people that analyze and interact with
this data
and ultimately to the decision makers
decision makers that have to
look at the data evaluate it and make
decisions about how to take the next
step
and so what we really arrive at is
at the challenge of multi-atomic
integration so when we talk about
multi-omics integration we're talking
about
the complex regulation of phenotypes
at the subcellular level where each
level of that regulation
can be studied at a distinct
type of data and each type of that data
is specific
as well as has a specific process
of translating that raw data
into information that we can later on to
use to study the system
as a whole so when we talk about this
process of integration we're really
talking about
looking at how bioinformatics can help
us understand the relationship between
the different clinical manifestations of
disease
the underlying omics data and the
utilization of this confirmation
for diagnostic and therapeutic purposes
so let me pause here and offer you
a few examples
as you all know when we look at a
patient
here you can see a mammogram or an x-ray
picture of the breast
where the doctors have to look
for abnormalities and once those
abnormalities are spotted
you have to make a decision about what
to do
about this abnormality right so here in
this example we can see
this white area this white area could
potentially be a tumor
and one of the things that the clinician
has to make a decision about
is what type of a malignant whether this
is a malignant growth a non-malignant
growth
and so what are the tools that are the
clinician has
to be able to make decisions about this
specific
growth one of the tools is you can start
looking for
what tissue this particular growth
is around or adjacent to so you can look
at for example the tumor being close to
different
types of tissues that are typically
present in breast tissue
and based on your ability to identify
visually where it is you can start
making some characterization of this
growth
however it's difficult from just an
x-ray to know
what to do and so often times people go
and extract some tissue biopsy
and they can now use staining or
antibodies that have different colors to
identify
presence and abundance of particular
types of receptors
so when we look at these receptors a
typical way to deal with breast cancer
classification
is to look for three different markers
or three different proteins
on the surface of the cell membrane that
allows us to easily understand
what type and classify categorize
what type of a cancer this might be now
over time people
have studied these types of cancers but
the problem is
that just looking at these membrane
markers
always leaves us in the dark about the
processes that are driving the disease
because the disease is not driven
by these external receptors it's really
driven
at a deeper level at what happens inside
the nucleus
at the dna level and the expression of
what's in the dna
and how it is different from normal
tissue
at this particular patient's body in
this particular patient's body
so over time molecular subtypes
have been developed looking at a
combination
of 50 to 100 different genes
that can inform our ability to diagnose
in a more precise way
what type of a disease this is how
dangerous it is
and inform our decisions about what to
do with these biomarkers so these
molecular subtypes that are
characterized by
molecular biomarkers are essentially
collections of genes and by
looking at sequencing data extracting
those genes
we can now characterize different types
of
breast cancer so here we have kind of
the evolution
of these breast cancer classification
which happened over time and over time
we've started understanding that even
this ability to characterize patients
and put them
into different groups is oftentimes
insufficient
in terms of accuracy of diagnosis
prognosis
and identification of the best response
to treatment
so here you can see an example of uh
kind of an
evolution in the different types of
panels that are used to classify and
categorize
these different types of patient
samples and the ability to really
understand
how we can both look at the association
of
clinical data about these types of
cancers
and functional classification that
allows us to spot
early on some processes that are
important for disease progression
metastasis cell adhesion different kind
of classical characteristics of cancer
so
how are these biomarkers used well
these biomarkers could be used to
diagnose
like we just looked at before it could
be
they could be used for predicting
survival
for example uh both of these panels pam
50 and oncotype dx
uh both of them consisting of just tens
of different molecular biomarkers
have been shown over the period of 10
times in clinic
or 10 years in clinical trials have been
shown to be associated with
high medium or low rate of recurrence
and rate of
rate of recurrence and
ability to predict the outcome and so
this is an important
tool in the toolkit of a clinician to be
able to make
important decisions about treatment when
we talk about
treatment the selection of treatment is
really driven
by a balance of cost benefit
to the patient oftentimes the treatments
that you have available for cancer
are highly toxic to all the other normal
cells in the body
and so being able to predict whether a
patient has
six months or ten years to live or is
likely to live
as a result of this particular cancer
might impact significantly the choice of
treatment that the clinician will
make importantly however as it was noted
in the very beginning
we are now entering a new era of
targeted therapy and in cancer this
targeted therapy
is driven by not only identification of
level of risk
but also identification of specific
features or specific players
in what's going on inside this tumor so
identifying
not only prognostic markers but actual
targets
we can now design treatments that can
interfere
with a molecular process and stop
different aspects of cancer
characteristics for example
one of these famous drugs is herceptin
herceptin is an antibody immunotherapy
that blocks a receptor on the surface of
the cell
it blocks and prevents it from signaling
to the nucleus on cell proliferation
which results in tumor growth
so we can see how this ability to
identify
what happens at the subcellular level
and not only at the membrane level
now helps us understand how this could
be
treated in a more effective way so for
example
immunotherapy has already transformed
cancer care and many of such precision
drugs are the result of biomedical
research studies of the tumor and not
only the tumor itself but also the
microenvironment
mapping the changes that characterize
tumors and
understanding the biological pathways
inside tumor cells and signaling between
tumors
and their micro environment have led to
innovative interventions that are
blocking suppressing
and enabling existing mechanisms of
action to mitigate the effects of
uncontrolled proliferation metastasis
so this is a drug called optivo
this drug was approved for medical use
in the united states in 2014 so
just six years ago it's on the world
health organization's list of essential
medicines
the safest and most effective medicines
needed in the health system
optivo is a medication used to treat a
number of types of cancer
including melanoma lung cancer renal
cell carcinoma hodgkin lymphoma head and
neck cancer
colon cancer and liver cancer and
these benefits of such targeted drugs
really require for analysis of data that
comes from these different tissues to
discover biomarkers
that will allow the clinician to guide
treatment selection
and evaluate the effectiveness of
treatment along the way
really placing data analysis at the
center of such precision treatments
so there are a few other examples like
opdevo for example
nivolumab is used as a first-line
treatment uh right so op devo comes in
in a
variety of uh different uh
packages and nivolumab was one of these
uh
other names for it and it's really
useful
for uh metastatic cancers and which is
very important and the mechanism of
action
uh is actually uh dependent on specific
mutations in different genes so we
really are looking at a a few examples
of how
receptor driven so gene expression and
protein
expression level mutation level
data all of these types of information
are really useful
for a clinician to make a decision but
here we're talking about some
advanced cancers or advanced medical
conditions
like a tumor that is proliferating and
already growing
what about early on well
increasingly it has become clear that
disease like cancer is not only caused
by genetic mutations and aberrations and
gene expression
of the host machinery really what's
become apparent
is that many diseases are driven
by variation at viral pathogenesis
that takes a long time to manifest
itself as a disease
it's also driven by changes in the
microbiome and composition of the
microbiome
and today we know that some of these
major players like the epstein-barr
virus the human papilloma virus and
hepatitis b and c
are major pathogens that over time can
cause
significant damage and inflammation to
healthy tissue
resulting many times in hundreds of
thousands of cases of cancer per year
globally so this ability to
identify at an early stage a presence of
a particular infection
infection and pathogen in the patient
is critical for our ability to intervene
earlier on
and also treat not only the
manifestation of disease
but also the agents that cause rise to
that disease so today when we talk about
cancers
the need for cancer diagnostics right if
we talk about
what's the impact of bioinformatics on
cancer treatments
you can see that actually applicable in
all
areas of cancer management which is
diagnostics so accurate diagnosis
uh using molecular profiles
understanding how different types of
genes
mutations epigenetic variation
are playing a role in accurate
diagnostics
on an individualized level it's
discovery
of targets like we just talked about of
targeted therapy that is going to impact
particular pathways
and mechanisms as well as identify what
is going on
what is driving that kind of aberration
predicting risk
prognosis so identification of specific
features that allow us today
to look at what will happen over the
course of the next several
years of a patient's life to understand
how the disease will progress and what
are some likely outcomes and risks
at the same time we're talking about
regular
application of data analysis to really
understand responses to treatment so
pharmacogenomic treatments
markers that understand that allow us to
track the effectiveness
as well as the potential dangers that
new treatments might
implement at the patient level and
finally
stratification so one of the challenges
today
is to accumulate knowledge about every
single one of these processes
making it possible for us to understand
how
a particular person or the markers that
we have
discovered characterize the biology of
this individual
so many times we have to rely on data
alone
to understand how patients could be
organized by groups
how they could be associated with a
group that is being studied in clinical
trials
how could it be associated with
experimental data
where we don't have data on patients but
we have a lot of data
at the cell line and the animal model
level
so really there's a huge need in regular
processing of data
as well as integration of this type of
data across a variety of different
domains so you might have heard
that in 2014 there was an
outbreak of ebola in west africa
this was one of the first pandemics or
epidemics because it was localized
that gave rise to a huge variety
of clinically applicable next generation
sequencing
data so the ebola outbreak of 2014 2016
really marks the beginning of
clinical use to study
epidemiological outbreaks of infectious
diseases
today we use this kind of information to
understand diseases
at a very detailed level and so the same
type of information that we've discussed
for cancer understanding and treatment
are now being applied
to study these infectious diseases and
more than
at any time previously we can appreciate
the impact of sequencing
on sars cove 2 or covet 19 right so
today
when we talk about sequencing data it's
not even something that you have to
explain the utility of
everybody understands that the
understanding of
the genome and understanding of how that
genome changes over time as it spreads
through
between different hosts like animals and
people
as it spreads between different
populations in different regions around
the world
we know that this kind of information at
the genomic level
really helps us study the disease to
generate information that is critical
for the next steps
as we try to intervene so when we talk
about these kinds of
findings we're really talking about a
variety of applications
of molecular sub-genomic data that
allows us to understand
both the epidemiology as well as the
application of this these findings to
novel treatments and an understanding of
the basic biology
so you've already probably seen how
uh very quickly uh from just
this year right starting in december
2019
and all the way until today uh thousands
and thousands of genomes from
patients throughout the whole world were
generated
many different collections uh were
prepared
in fact you now have a whole source a
whole list
of sources and databases that you can
research and explore
uh genomic data on covet 19
and what's important about the growing
availability of this data
is that it is becoming more and more
complicated and at the same time
informative so what we can see
here is the ability to track
mutations worldwide understand
how this type of mutation data or
genomic data
can explain variability of disease
and we can study how host factors
right the response of different
individuals
young old of different genders and
backgrounds
with other types of comorbidities helps
us to translate that data
into models that actually inform not
only
an individual treatment or individual
interaction with a patient but actually
at a global scale
right we now know that this kind of
genomic data
is impacting decisions by governments
impacting decisions by health systems
it's helping
health systems develop novel diagnostic
tools
and we are looking at a particularly
fascinating in my opinion trend where we
are
discovering how drugs could be
repurposed
as well as uh modified to
uh address specific challenges like what
we're seeing with covet 19.
so here you can see a couple of
publications that were focused on
the integration of molecular information
like the
protein sub network associated so code
19
and human associated host proteins sub
network
the interaction between the viral
proteins
and the human proteins and an associated
network
of protein drug target network
and based on that information you can
actually find
important clicks of that system of that
network
to target a particular interaction
with an already known drug and so really
this is called
network-based drug repurposing where you
can analyze
networks of drug interactions protein
interactions host pathogen interactions
and identify some effective breaking
points that might
be accessible that could be further
studied however
not only is this driven by uh
more kind of like uh not knowledge
driven and it's really data driven
research because ultimately the proposed
approach then what you can see here on
the right
is the approach of high throughput
sequencing
uh both in uh cell line experiments
where you can
rank compounds and rank there by you
know efficacy
as well as uh testing of those compounds
on animals animal models of human
disease
and in all of these different aspects
from cell line experiments
to animal models to that application to
human population all of this is driven
by this ability to integrate data and
track
similar patterns across the different
domains
so that we can inform decisions at every
step
of the way so to summarize
how is such high throughput data
transforming the clinical and
pharmaceutical industry when we talk
about the applications of bio
informatics to biomedical research we're
really talking about
clinical uses such as patient
stratification
disease classification and diagnostics
identification of potential responders
to therapies as well as the study of the
mechanisms of disease
onset and progression at a much deeper
level
and at the pharmaceutical level we're
really talking about
discovery of biomarkers detection of
toxicity at the in vitro stage so before
it reaches the clinical
application analysis of molecular
mechanisms of
drug action or target discovery as well
as drug repurposing and rare positioning
the amazing thing that we're seeing
today is that the wider
biomedical community is becoming much
much more open
because the need for data analysis
skills
tools and an understanding of the
important applications of these methods
is becoming more of a need than
privilege
right so previously a lot of this kind
of research was very
diverse and separated and required
highly expert
highly trained experts that could
participate
in such studies today the need is much
bigger and so it is becoming much much
more open and ripe
for disruption the key for closing the
gap
between the ability to cheaply generate
data
and making sense of how to use this data
are really tools skills and
a deep understanding of the application
so what we do is provide
such training sorry let me
go back here what we do what our company
does
to address this gap is we provide
a collection of tools and training
to discover the important questions
such as the ones that i have described
today in this presentation
and plan for a
an environment an ecosystem where one
can flourish
and develop independent projects using
this type of data
and showing the impact on a particular
domain
so our omnics logic training programs
i'll briefly describe those
are really designed of several
components and i think it's important to
understand how they could be helpful
both in the long term for impact on
health care
but both from an educational and
academic perspective
how they can translate a program that
deals with bioinformatics or biomedical
research
to make them more effective at
addressing these problems
at the industry level so what we offer
are interactive sessions self-guided
materials that
are packaged under these different
collections
as well as practical assignments and
these
elements together provide a resource
that can supplement any kind of an
academic program
to really make a translational impact
on how these types of materials and data
sets
could be applied to solve real
challenges so what we hope to do as a
result of
doing this for the past couple of years
is to provide
a clear perspective on bioinformatics
machine learning and artificial
intelligence in research
clinical and industry applications the
way we do this as i mentioned
is by providing access to tools and
enabling infrastructure to deal with big
data
and i'll talk about this in a second we
also
provide the logic of analysis
in application to real data sets so we
don't just deal with hypotheticals we
actually take the examples like what
we've talked about
up until now different types of cancers
different types of treatments
different types of risks and strategies
different clinical interactions
as well as epidemiological genomic data
we also provide practical applications
to a variety of projects so our goal is
to prepare a person and provide them
with
a springboard to jump into a real
situation
that might have an impact that there is
some area of that data set that is
unexplored
and you can really try to make a
difference a lot of these different
types of projects really deal
with the ability to integrate multiple
factors that cause disease and drive
disease progression
that includes cellular omics so a
variety of different types of omics at
the cellular and subcellular level
the microbiome and the viral as well as
the integration with clinical or
phenotypic data and as you can imagine a
lot of these different associations or
correlations are
non-linear complex and require
a lot of manipulation and playing around
with
to really arrive at discovery if you
were to try and do that
on your own system using only the
resources that are available to you you
will click
quickly run into the problem of time
every single step of the way
to process this data to try and
integrate different parameters
of the data that you found requires a
lot of time
and so a critical part of what we
provide
is facilitating infrastructure to speed
up that process
in fact we've developed a multi-omics
integration
platform it's a cloud-based platform
that
allows us to streamline the process
of generating structured data and mining
it for associations what types of
methods does this platform include
as i mentioned this is a multi-omics
data so it really has
different types of sections like next
generation sequencing data analysis
mass spec data structural biology data
as well as a whole section on
integration and modeling
within each section to speed up the
process
of understanding the logic of analysis
we provide
demo pipelines that you can try and run
with a demo data set to really
understand
what are the inputs and outputs and the
logic of how to
build a pipeline that's going to be
effective
there's also a more growing interest in
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and so we believe that
every bioinformatician today needs to be
familiar with some of the
these technologies how they operate
what are the different uh settings
for using them effectively but also how
to apply them to solve particular
problems
and finally we provide tracking and
resource management
that allows you to easily transition
between a an educational situation
to an application so actually there's a
transition
from basic to project based
education to then application this to
real research projects so in fact we
have collaborations with many different
universities
that are focused on application of many
of these different processing tools
and analysis tools to translational
research projects
many of these projects many of these
types of processing data pipelines
are really designed to provide a
combination
of color-coded maps uh explained methods
that you can really
dive deeper into what each method does
and understand
what are the parameters that are
important for running that properly
outputs that are both visual and
technical that you can utilize in a
future downstream analysis
and importantly a reproducible workflow
that reproducible workflow
allows us to provide high quality
technical support
and understand what are the what are the
challenges that participants
face as well as understand for you
for a user of these types of tools to be
able to share
your analysis in a very simple way for
other people to benefit from in addition
to this platform we provide training
resources that are really
packaged course materials that could
could be supplemented for any other type
of bioinformatics training
that explain this kind of logic at a
very user friendly level
as well as on a more technical level
going behind the scenes
and understanding what are some of the
coding skills that are required to run
these types of analysis
in both r and python
moreover and i think very importantly is
that
this type of education is really project
driven
and i think that if we are trying to
make a difference
in the way that precision medicine is
improved by application of
bioinformatics to high global data sets
it's important to understand that these
types of skills are applied
at all level of biomedical research and
all the way
to clinical applications and so we've
really worked hard
on uh interacting with our partners from
academic centers and clinical centers
to source projects of high impact that
could explain
some of these paradigms that we've
discussed uh in the
workshop and how bioinformatics could be
applied
to see them in a real project so when i
say project
i really mean taking a publication from
a high
impact journal understanding what type
of data was used in a particular study
and with what types of methods it was
analyzed
and looking at that published and
digested example it's not a textbook
example it's an example from a real
study and we try to keep them up to date
as much as possible
you can start understanding how the
methods and the data combined
together could actually yield a novel
idea
which is independent and turns into a
project of your own
so what types of projects are am i
talking about
one example of a project is exactly like
what we discussed
with
with bioinformatics for precision
medicine
or for breast cancer classification
and selecting biomarkers to
allow for precision treatment of breast
cancer so in this example
you can just look at the abstract and
immediately understand
what the authors were trying to do what
they did
is evaluate the benefit
of different types of molecular data
seven different data types to associate
with different types of
clinical trial level drugs as well as
approved on the market drugs
to understand how you could develop a
an analysis workflow to select
the optimal treatment for a particular
patient
but this is just one example so in fact
we have a variety of projects
these projects range from cancer to
neuroscience to agriculture
to different types of infectious disease
studies that i think all
illustrate how important bioinformatics
can be
in this process of changing healthcare
the way that we know it today
making it more impactful at an
individual level
making it more precise and less toxic
with less side effects
and ultimately driving the
treatment of these complex diseases to
allow
for an effective treatment of diseases
that have not
been able to been uh treated before
right so many diseases
uh that we know of today including
copenhagen really do not have an
effective strategy to be prevented or
treated
at this moment and bioinformatics is i
think very key
to discovery and uh application of these
treatments
so what kind of impact have we made so
far
i think that you know it is uh easy for
us to kind of look back
at the last year and know that this
impact is really providing results so
what
what i've seen is thousands of students
including high school students
undergraduates
graduate and even postgraduate students
including postdocs
and researchers that have seen how these
programs help them
address challenges in research discover
new information that was previously
unaccessible to them
and ultimately make a difference so our
programs
include a variety of different types of
basic training but also because i know
that
many of you are graduate students and
post-docs i did want to mention that we
have
a research fellowship that our company
supports which is a program specifically
designed for those that are interested
to apply
bioinformatics to some of these cutting
edge precision medicine related
projects so this research fellowship
program
includes uh you know really uh
experience
in application of bioinformatics to big
high throughput
omics data where we help find and select
an appropriate project and data set
we help master the tools that are
cloud-based and
effective at discovering specific
patterns
in different types of omics data
understanding of how that different type
of
different types of omics data play a
role in different types of biomedical
studies
and ultimately we also help develop
a set of kind of validated
projects or skill sets that you can
later on take
with you when you apply it to your
research
or industry applications when you might
be
participating in the industry
uh research with these bioinformatics
tools
so at this point um maybe we can share
the link
just for those that are interested in
some of these programs
we have this research fellowship program
that i invite you to look at
and also if you have any questions
i would be happy to answer any questions
that you might have at this time
thank you and beeps um
posted some of those links uh in the
chat for those of you
that are interested to take a look
[Music]
hello yes
yes i'm muslim doctor
so i need to ask you one thing oh
if you really are looking for some
special skill
before we enter to this research
fellowship as such we
talk about what's to the prerequisite
if you want to apply
so there's really two options for the
research fellowship
one research uh fellowship option is a
three-month
accelerated program for those that are
already familiar with some basic
bioinformatics
so they are familiar with different
types of omix data they are familiar
with processing tools from omix data
they're really ready to start a research
project so that typically lasts about
three months and the goal is to make an
impact so driven by a poster
presentation at the end of that process
or a research publication
and we have a community of people that
you can collaborate with
in that project the other option is for
those that do not have those skills so
they really
are interested they maybe know the
biology or some clinical application
that they see themselves driven by but
they don't have
a lot of coding skills they don't have
the biostatistics skills they don't have
the bioinformatics skills
so that program is six months and that
includes training which includes access
to all of our programs that are ongoing
so you can explore different tools and
different project examples
and then at the at the end of that
process you still have the three months
to develop an independent project
so if you talk about this project
fellowship so are we
getting some sort of a degree of
certification
after completing the product on the pro
output of the project will be a
propriety product of a company
no no the output of the program is
a project that uh you take with you so
the objective of this is to develop
a research uh presentation uh which
could be a poster or a publication
or a main and so really that is the
outcome
and it's not for undergraduate so it's
not certificate based it's really based
on that project outcome right so our
goal is to type
what we do to support that yeah one
thing one thing more
one thing more if we enrolled in this
particular six month project
so the tools will be learning
so it can be used in our online or open
source system
or you have to be dependent on all your
services you are providing
no no you you can use it we provide you
with cloud access to our tools if you're
interested to implement those tools in
other
infrastructure you're welcome to do that
and we can help you set that up as well
okay okay okay thank you
what is the cost of the internship
program for research fellowship
there are two different modes here like
i said three months and six months
so if you're interested in that you can
probably
email to marketing at pine bio
and all the details could be sent to you
by email
for those of you that are interested in
um
doing more with your bioinformatics and
becoming a part
of a growing bioinformatics community
that is
applying these kinds of tools to a
variety of different
challenges we also welcome you to join
some of our
community on uh social media we have a
group on
linkedin with over 500 professionals
from these different pharmaceutical and
clinical
uh applications of bioinformatics as
well as the group of over 5000 people on
facebook that you're welcome to join as
well
okay what would be the difference
between these two internships really
it's the length
and that's dependent on your background
how much background do you have
in bioinformatics that's for a rouge
uh newport um can it be pursued during
postgraduate course yes
so we have a lot of people that are are
post-docs
phd students and even researchers that
work together
as group projects many times you you
have a faculty member that is driving
the research project
and would like to rely on some student
support or
you know other type of support so yeah
there's opportunities for those as well
if you have a master's in bioinformatics
yes you're definitely more uh
the more applicable is the three months
internship
and uh beeps are posted there a link to
our
uh linkedin group so you're welcome to
join that group
uh we hope to to use this group to make
introductions uh you know there's a lot
of
job postings in both academia and
industry
if you already know bioinformatics and
and have something to show and what we
hope
also as a result of this research
fellowship program is to
show how you can improve uh
your um uh your cv or your
um your way that you present uh what you
know about bioinformatics
when you apply for um you know these
kinds of positions
uh the eligibility is really um
like i said there's two different types
of programs three months and six months
the three months program if you want to
get into that program
you have to already know bioinformatics
which
includes either a certificate that you
already have for bioinformatics training
program
uh such as the ones that we provide or
many other universities we provide
or a degree in bioinformatics if you do
not have a degree or a certificate
program then you can still get into the
six months fellowship and that will give
you both the training
and the ability to then develop a
project of your own
okay
well again it was uh great for me to be
able to speak with you today
i'm excited that we will be able to form
a
longer term relationship with punjab
university
and explore a lot of these topics in
greater detail
for sure we've done a lot of and for
a lot of collaborations that lead to
research projects at the end at
you know both individual uh student
level but also at the
program and university level so that's
really the hope for
on our side okay so a question from a
rouge
you have a master's in biotechnology but
your research was related to
bioinformatics
um again i would recommend emailing
bibsa um with your current cv
or she also has a link
vipsa maybe you could post a link again
once you submit the form
we will be able to better address the
needs of the program
for your individual case
okay uh there's a um
okay let's take a look if there's a
problem with the link
okay so this is the link you can see
here
um some information about this
so it seems to be working if you're
having trouble please again
email beeps and we'll be able to send
you that information by email
all right great well i see many of you
are now joining the linkedin group so
it's great to have you
with us here and you can explore some of
the members
and have a lot of experience in
different areas of industry and academia
and okay will we share the stations
okay so maybe just in closing i also
have
another meeting here that is coming up
but in closing
i would like to share with you that we
do have two other
upcoming programs one is focused on
metagenomics or a program on
microbiome that is for
people that do have some familiarity
with bioinformatics we'll go through
some of the typical tools and some
exciting project examples
that are related to therapeutics and
related to different diseases so i
welcome you to
take a look at those as well as a
program on transcriptomic data analysis
so it's
real training on rna-seq including bulk
rna-seq and
single-cell rna-seq so you're welcome to
join the transcriptomics to explore the
transcriptomics program as well
those will be starting soon we do have a
growing presence and different
universities in india and we hope to
develop more so
we also are hoping to develop joint
certificate programs
because there's really a huge demand for
these types of skills
internationally and especially in the
era of covet as you know
you can definitely work from home and so
a lot of
companies and physicians are looking for
that kind of uh
support uh dr uh
kumar thank you again for yes
this interaction was very interesting
and we
get a lot of opportunity to ask and
interact
so we'll hopefully we'll be interacting
with you more
and thank you very much for your
presentation and then
i think participants are much more clear
what is possible and they'll be
interacting with you more directly on
email
in conclusion we can say we want to say
anything then we can conclude
yes dr thank you so much uh for this
webinar and i think
it was really useful in terms of
understanding the application of this
technology
and i'm really happy that all the
participants were able to
join and ask questions and we will be
sharing the
video of this session to everyone so
that they can review it later as well
so thank you again everyone okay
okay then we can say conclude so we can
declare this meeting and add is that
okay okay
great yeah thank you very much and
looking forward to
continuing this interaction talk take a
good night
thank you good night thank you